So everything is just falling apart for Donald
Trump.
Not only that, his niece write a horrifying
book about him.
Not only did his sister get caught on leaked
audio slamming him, but now there are reports
that Donald Trump's own wife, Melania Trump,
the first lady, has been caught on tape making
disparaging comments about both Donald Trump
himself and his children.
The recording has been reportedly made by
Stephanie Winston Wolkoff, who's a former
adviser to Melania, and she's going to be
putting out a book in September called Melania
and Me.
The Rise and Fall of My Friendship with the
First Lady.
Now, this is essentially gossip in a sense,
but it's gossip that goes to the same story.
Trump doesn't have normal relationships.
He's not a normal person.
Many of the people around him are around him,
not just because they enjoy it, but for who
knows what kinds of other reasons.
And much like he ruins personal relationships,
he ruins our relationship as a country with
our allies.
He's just ruining everything that he touches.
Now, the book will eventually have the details.
It'll be released in September.
Presumably audio will also be released.
But reportedly, Melania Trump in these recordings
attacks Ivana Trump.
I guess Melania really doesn't like Vanka
and attacks Donald Trump himself and attacks
Trump's other adult children.
So this is really just a reality show.
And and again, as I said just a few minutes
ago in the last story, I look forward to and
would welcome gladly a boring Biden presidency
and things just being boring for a while while
Donald Trump is gone.
Now, this is the same adviser to Melania,
by the way, writing this book that told Melania.
Remember when they came up with that B best
thing?
And it sounded just like a grammatical mistake.
This same adviser to Melania, who reportedly
recorded Melania disparaging Trump and his
children, told Melania that her B best slogan
sounded alliterate, which it does.
I mean, it sounds illiterate and it also sounds
potentially place plagiarized, which I'm actually
less sure about, if nothing else, removing
this and putting the Biden family in the White
House.
It would just be a breath of fresh air to
just make this garbage stop.
Boring presidency I welcome.
And I can tell you boring won't be particularly
good for my business, but who cares?
It'll be good for the country.
A scandal a day, you know, white knuckling
it with some new scandal every single week.
It really is exhausting.
Now, to be clear.
Biden being boring doesn't mean we stop paying
attention if Biden wins.
It doesn't mean we stop lobbying for progressive
change.
It just means the process gets back to one
of being mildly connected to how modern Western
democracies are supposed to operate.
Now, of course, if Biden is president, Fox
News will find scandals.
They will fabricate scandals.
They will concoct scandals if they need to.
But they will be similar to Obama wore a tan
suit.
Obama's choice of mustard was arrogant or
whatever the other side to this is that there
will be so much damage to clean up and most
likely a Biden presidency will be dealing
with at least six months of Trump continuing
to be triggered constantly by Biden starting
to undo the damage Trump has done.
Joe Biden will still be dealing with a pandemic.
Nothing is fixed.
If Biden becomes president, it gives us the
ball back to use that analogy again.
And we can start to fix things.
We'll still have the pandemic.
The economic recovery from Trump's mishandling
of the pandemic is likely to take all of Joe
Biden's first term.
If he were to get one.
But just for context, and I know that this
is crazy to think back to.
There were periods of time during Barack Obama's
presidency where we didn't cover Obama even
for an entire week.
Never mind every day, like there were times
when the president just did their job and
we talked about other things, what was going
on in the Senate, geopolitics and much else,
because there wasn't constantly some fire
to be putting out.
They seemed like simpler times in some ways.
Now back to the recordings of Melania slamming
Trump briefly.
It really would be great if they were released
this week during the RNC.
Just a thought Trump would fly off the rails
and I would love to see it.
Let me know if anybody else is thinking along
the same lines.